capital one sent out a contract update
to all the people that have their credit
cards and in it it said basically that
they can now drop by your house
unannounced so here these are literal
these are actual quotes we're not making
this up we may contact you in any manner
we choose and that includes showing up
your house such contacts can include
calls emails texts faxes or a personal
visit these personal visits can be at
your home and at your place of
employment we may modify or suppress
caller ID and similar services and
identify ourselves on these services in
any manner we choose meaning we can fake
the phone number that we're dialing from
and then pretend or somebody else we can
also show up by your house baba by now a
lot of people have already said well
this is a violation of the Fourth
Amendment that's not quite true because
the the Fourth Amendment is about the
government uh you you know search and
seizure so obviously Capital One and
credit card companies are not the
government yet but it's getting pretty
close is this just [ __ ] absurd I
think it's okay if they show up at your
house in a white shirt a black tie and
ask you if you heard the good news about
capital one that is right yeah like
we've increased your credit line and you
don't have to pay off your debt yeah I'm
used to this because I get my visa to
the NSA and so I've have been useless
like this is great at it is unbelievable
and what is where they want to come to
my place of employment for because I
have a credit card like well I think
this is all about scaring you so that if
you get into debt and then in the old
days when they could just make phone
calls well I think they want you to fear
that they're gonna literally show up at
your house you can already haunt you
forever you can't get rid of your credit
card debt anymore because they rerigged
the rules so I don't understand so this
is just more fears is just more fear and
the fact that they're saying this is
what we're gonna do with the phone calls
to we're going to pretend to be someone
else there be actual visit God's showing
up the power yeah okay so I think so no
I'm out I don't like Alec Baldwin
anymore now because of this to God he
say what did you call him a farts music
he's a mother [ __ ] fart snorkel yeah
that's yeah you didn't think you were
gonna get to use that joke anymore did
you it is
there you go a little time for jimmy
dore up but really like how much of this
also is just that these freaking things
that we sign you know that you
immediately just click accept accept and
you we'd look we do this with itunes
just as easily we do a credit card how
much of it is just that you don't do the
lawyer on retainer sitting next to all
the time when you're about to sign up
for something certainly when i'm on
facebook i do that is a hair that is
really scary you know because if you
don't realize that when you leave
facebook when you go to another website
there's he don't sign out from facebook
facebook's gathering all your data so
when you go back to facebook you're like
oh my god there's a ad for penis
enlargers i thought what am i doing yeah
you know that has nothing to do with
what i was doing on facebook nothing to
do why is that happening yeah so while
it that was because i was looking for
black hookers and they knew i was like
an appointment google chrome incognito
ah yeah the thing what is it really yeah
even if i put on private browsing that
still goes back to facebook no i don't
know we don't know we're not well even
way I got pretty sure we're all agreed
it goes to the NSA so it doesn't yeah so
forget about Facebook but really this
thing with the with the pages in page a
thing you can't have a lawyer with you
all the time even if you were a lawyer
are you going to read every lever each
one of those agree nobody that's what
one ever so what is the point of that
even could that hold up in court well he
did check the I agree things with itunes
and if you try I've tried to be a good
citizen I've tried to edit so many words
that I've never heard of in an order
I've never seen them that I'm already
ruined before I get through the first
sentence yeah so is this just the next
step in how we've watched our privacy
erode I mean right between the NSA and
what we know what's going on with
Facebook and everything else that sure
now not only do you know where we are we
have GPS em we've given you all our
information but also show up at my house
well you want lunch can i get a lot I
mean really is that is that the next
step like it's just been systematic
erosion well this is a why not it's it's
actually worse than 1984 it's worse than
the TV screen that can see you because
they can see you when you leave the TV
screen they see you everywhere you go no
matter where you are they know where you
are what you're doing who you had dinner
with who you exact who you're cavorting
with they know more stuff from their
metadata than they do if they were
active listening you
actually to that point you actually it's
actually worse than that I think too you
know why they know what we had for
dinner and who you're with because
they've armed us with Lee with the
weapons to police ourselves yes and so
it's not about you know like big brother
it's about here this is really fun and
slides cameras over to us and gets us
hooked on it gets me hooked on it Google
glass that now they're talking about
don't be a glass hole and and and take
people when they don't know it and all
this [ __ ] but we're having fun with it
too so they don't really have room to
talk yes so they give us snapchat people
send all these pictures thinking they're
you know gonna disappear in six seconds
yeah then of course we find out last
week that snapchats been compromised not
only it within snapchat itself but
within your entire phone you have
snapchat has never been harder to be a
14 year old girl and I am so glad I'm
not one yeah oh my god nobody's ever
heard of just taking a screenshot of
some poor child I've never been 14 year
old boys who have been harder I think
that was a fitting a talent